hi there steve kaufman
um let me just get this centered better
today was a great day here um
i went skiing cross-country skiing in
vancouver
uh it was raining
last couple of days and the temperature
dropped and so there was lots of snow up
here in the mountains so 20 minutes from
where i live
i went from a rainy weather to beautiful
snow
had a great time
and i have my frozen shoulder and uh at
least i'm able to cross-country ski so
that makes me a little happier otherwise
my activities have been really cut back
i can't play hockey i can't do anything
but uh today was great
now i want to talk uh in response to a
comment that kevin made on a previous
post
uh
where i spoke i think i commented about
where i
made reference to a site that referred
to english people not speaking languages
although a number of them said they
would like to
and kevin said well yeah but the english
are not the only ones that are
monolingual and which is true but of
course they're more monolingual
than the others like uh when i was in
italy all kinds of people spoke english
portugal the same way
but it's not really fair to compare
because really the english i mean
everyone speaks english so there is less
incentive for them to speak english
and kevin then sent me
in the direction of an article by a mark
morgenfelder i think it was and i've
posted a connection to or a link to his
article
where he explains all the reasons why
people don't want to learn
languages and he says that it's a very
difficult it's an unpleasant thing to do
and people only do it if they have to
so i want to talk about that because i
want to compare language learning to
golf now i could compare language
learning to sudoku or learning to play a
musical instrument or any other
thing
hobby activity that people to do people
do because they like to do those
activities
and
to me and i
you know yeah i'm a bit of a language
nut
uh
but
uh
language learning
should be an enjoyable thing to do
and i
am of the belief
and that's largely behind my motivation
and link
i'm of the belief that more people don't
learn languages because it is made out
to be an obligation something that we
have to do and so forth and so on
now if you look at golf if you compare
golf
to
language learning i mean language
learning is much more pleasant
you are far more likely to succeed
you're far less likely to be frustrated
it's a lot less expensive
uh and it's better for you it's better
for your brain
and i mean you look at golf and i play
golf i'm not as keen as my wife but i do
play golf i went through a period where
i tried very hard to improve
i realized that no matter how hard i
practiced i wasn't going to get any
better that every time i go out to play
golf there's going to be x number of
times when i'll hit that ball and it
won't go anywhere near where i wanted it
to go
so you know four and a half five hours
walking around the golf course and
increasingly you don't even get to walk
you have to ride in a cart
so there's very little exercise
lots of frustration it's expensive it's
50 60 70 80 if you go to an expensive
course 100 150
for the privilege of going around and
being frustrated and most people never
improve i mean the young people improve
and then they
you know the older people most of the
people who take it up are older and they
very quickly reach their level and they
never ever improve
uh yeah it's social me with friends
whatever that's true have a beer after
the game and all that but
if i compare it to language learning
language learning is very good stimulus
for the brain if you do it right you're
actually doing interesting things
listening to interesting things reading
interesting things
you're able to track your improvement
and again at length you know you're
gradually seeing a number of words that
you know increase it's actually
cumulative golf isn't cumulative you can
play well one day practice the whole
week and play worse the following week
there is no sense of of an accumulation
whereas in language learning you do
accumulate words
uh the other thing is you know you can
learn languages while doing exercises
that are far more physical exercise
that's far more strenuous than golf i do
it all the time when i was up skiing
cross-country skiing in the snow i was
listening to russian
my my wife gets furious because i will
play golf listening to languages
when i i can be exercising lifting
weights doing my abdominal exercises
listening to languages i can be walking
listening to languages
so it's healthy it's good for the brain
and at the end of it
you actually end up being able to speak
in the language
okay you end up with something
something's left
so
to me yeah there's all kinds of
hobbies that that are out there and not
everyone's going to like the same thing
and i i have always said
i don't consider someone who isn't
interested in languages a worse person
you know there's lots of multilingual
people who i don't like and there's lots
of unilingual people that i like it
doesn't make you a better or worse
person but i think we can do a much
better job
of making language learning an
interesting and fun activity for its own
sake just the pleasure of listening to a
different language
and
in fact this article by this mark
fellow
there's a lot that i agree with in what
he says about things that are not true
about language learning but the idea
that language learning has to be a
utilitarian
activity that you only do it if you have
to i just i think that's true for a lot
of people maybe even be true for the
majority of people
but people do lots of things that are
not utilitarian people play golf which
has no purpose and it's expensive and
frustrating
people do sudoku which has no purpose so
can we not structure language learning
in such a way that it is a fun thing to
do for its own sake the activity of
learning of listening is fun
and you get the added benefit that you
now have a language which will enable
you to communicate with people whether
it be socially or for business or for
watching movies or for reading books you
now acquire this
other door
to a part of humanity you know that has
been kind of off limits
for you so that you have these
tremendous benefits and in that sense
i think it's really unfortunate
that this whole utilitarian approach to
language learning
you know and you've got to learn it as
fast as possible and do it and be done
with it no no just do it and enjoy it
and
don't just do english or now chinese or
spanish
there used to be far more
interest in a variety of languages
language exchanges to germany to japan
to portugal to i don't know
kyrgyzstan
it doesn't matter it's wherever you go
and you meet up with people of a
different culture and you learn their
language if it's done
well learning that language can be fun
and you end up with the advantage that
you now can
interact
in a much richer way with the people and
the culture of a different language so
my take on it is i would far rather
go
cross-country skiing by the way i went
cross-country skiing today and listened
to echo mesquite my russian my wife
played golf if you ask me what i would
rather do
the proof is where i went today and
where she went today so
let us continue to find ways to make
language learning a fun thing to do not
just
uh utilitarian activity so that's my
take on language learning and golf
thank you